hi i'm maria as always i've been
challenged to take a common food and
make it fancy let's see what we are
making fancy today
pizza lunchable i had cheese and cracker
lunchable i liked what i made it was one
of my favorite episodes oh it's big
it's almost look like pita bread like
counting money it's very red those look
like they put some basil and shredded
mozzarella cheese there used to be a red
stick to spread the sauce oh
they got rid of the red stick why
we don't know
okay
like this
circular you can use pepperoni
if you want to spread with the cheese i
really want to toast it
um
personally i don't like leftover cold
pizza i want to toast that
sending back
this looks much more appetizing
oh yeah this makes so much better as
always i'm excited to make it fancy
all right here's what i got oregano
basil parsley heavy cream eggs parmesan
cheese garlic butter shredded mozzarella
cheese fresh mozzarella cheese rada and
milk from the pantry i got olive oil
salt panko all-purpose flour italian
seasoning onion powder and garlic powder
okay let's get started
make it fuzzy
first step i'm going to just use
pepperoni from lunchable cup to
start
kinda become a little small cube oil
heating up for frying dropping a heated
oil so i just wanted to make it like
crisp up once it kind of stopped
bubbling it's ready to go and if you
leave in the oil too long it gets burned
quickly so maybe like 10 to 15 seconds
transfer to paper towel lined plate so
it's observe extra grease these are
looking good ready to move on i forgot
to wear apron so i'm going to wear april
next six tablespoons of butter just melt
really there were actually some
alternative names for lunchables let me
know if you like them okay
oh yeah
yeah i mean it's realistic 3 4 cup of
flour whisk that in so when you whisk
the flour in you kind of make this kind
of dough and you're going to slowly add
whole milk 2 cups you don't want to all
the milk at once so if you do that it
makes a lot of lumps i'm making bechamel
sauce which is one of the mother songs
so this is kind of like basic sauce you
will learn culinary school if you go one
this is a little bit thicker than
regular bechamel and you want to
constantly whisk so it's become like
very smooth bechamel sauce i add all the
milk i want to reduce a little bit to
thicken and i'm adding one half teaspoon
of onion powder
one half teaspoon of italian seasoning
one half teaspoon of garlic powder one
teaspoon of salt so you have to
constantly whisk until get very thick i
feel like bechamel is most particible
[Music]
i think tomato sauce tasted fine it just
tasted like pizza sauce did i say basil
[Laughter]
dried basil yes i got cheese shower it's
something like alex would do
miss you the consistency you're looking
for it's like very smooth mashed potato
i'm adding quarter cup of parmesan
cheese quarter cup of shredded
mozzarella i feel like i have mortality
on my neck too i'm adding all the cheese
from lunchable
it's a little sweet so i'm going to add
a quarter spoon of salt add crisp
pepperoni look like a thousand island
dressing add in a bowl put a piece of
plastic make sure
the plastic touches your bechamel i'm
going to chew this for two hours and
while it's in the fridge i'm going to
move on to next step using the last
component of pizza lunchable i'm going
to bake this at 400 degrees around 10
minutes until crisp up pizza crust it's
perfectly crisp now
and i'm gonna break up so
nice and uniform grind this up
i feel are having trouble
opening up and break big piece by hand
or to panko give a good mix and save
this for later moving on grated parmesan
cheese scoop with one teaspoon we put
this parmesan cheese on a baking sheet
with parchment paper on and put kind of
amount and then use your finger
gently top a little bit flat i'm going
to bake this 350 degree oven about three
to five minutes until the edge is
slightly golden brown
this is just out from oven and you have
to move quick scrape this cheese while
it's still warm using a gravity and you
can kind of drape kind of like
taco shape set this aside about 20
minutes until this get hardened on to
the next step half cup of olive oil two
tablespoons of water one and a half cup
of basil quarter cup of parsley two
tablespoons of parmesan cheese one clove
of garlic and half teaspoon of salt
all right so it's well branded just for
you know fancy touch
we are going to put in a squeeze bottle
this is a little bit looser than your
ordinary pesto usually you don't use
parsley for pesto but this is for just
color and presentation right sauce it's
done and we got more cheese to use two
bowls of broth it's a little bit more
creamier and richer than mozzarella and
we are putting in a food processor and
make it a little bit looser add one
tablespoon of heavy cream
the texture you are looking for is a
soft whipped cream so just process first
and if the texture looks too stiff add
heavy cream to adjust put this in a
piping bag use a spatula and scrape it
down and we are going to use it for
later and until then i'm going to keep
this in the fridge to chill so we have
chilled bechamel mix right here cubed
fresh mozzarella all purpose flour egg
wash and panko mixed with pizza
lunchable crust form this into a little
bowl
and quarter cup each
make a little bit flat and put the cubed
fresh mozzarella in it this is a little
bit like pinkish color because we used
pizza lunchables pizza sauce in the
bechamel and also we used fried and
crisped pepperoni i was able to make 10
bowls
with flour toss
so you don't have excess flour drop in
egg wash make sure coat them evenly drop
in panko
i think the crust from pizza rancho bowl
gives a little bit different texture and
color which i like it's lunchable for
american kids it's this lunch or snack
special lunch
i got last one here
yeah it's
cute it's round because anything around
is cute these are looking good i'm going
to fry these pot of oil heat it for 350
degrees and i don't want to crowd
the pot so i'm going to fry three at the
time cook until outside it's golden
brown about three to four minutes right
so this one looking good nice brown when
it's ready the bowl kind of comes up to
the surface and that's also another sign
of ready some of them is explodes that's
fine
doesn't need to look too perfect like a
personality these are looking good and
i'm going to fry rest of the bowls and
move on i made a lot of things so let's
recap pizza lunchable croquettes i have
parmesan cheese crisps and basil sauce
and whipped brother and fresh herbs for
decoration so it's just plating so it's
just uh do whatever you wanna do
when i took a photo styling class i was
told to usually use other number i'm
kind of following that got whipped prada
adding cheese crisp on top the fresh
oregano here and there
just like small top heart of basil for
decoration adding one more cheese crisp
and we are done
[Music]
pizza lunchable croquettes
very fancy
right let's give this a try overall it
looks beautiful i like vibrant color
different texture
[Music]
pizza sauce bechamel is very creamy and
we also put fresh mozzarella in a middle
so it kind of have a gooey cheese
texture it's rich but it's not too heavy
so you can definitely eat three of those
the pesto kinda gives nice flesh flavor
it complements cheesecrocker is nice and
crispy i think it's a big improvement
from pizza lunchable thank you so much
for watching i highly recommend you make
a home and if you make a home please tag
me on instagram and don't forget to
dance make it fancy
[Music]